[Music]
hello and welcome to playstation grenade
it's fortnite update time again and like
usual this is the place to be to come to
find those map
updates on the island of battle royale
this week it's week 10 of chapter two
season five
and we have plenty to go through which
also includes things which will be
popping up over the next week
you know like a leviathan head waiting
for a valentine's dinner
it's weird but that's just life so sit
your butt down for 10 minutes do me a
favor and slap code adamara in the store
and let's break everything down
[Music]
first this episode i shall be donning
this skin and right away i need your
help
this character's name is spelt v i
the problem i have now is how the heck
do you pronounce that
is it v or is it vi i don't know which
to commit to right now
how are you pronouncing this name let me
know because i think she's going to be
important in the weeks to come in the
future
so the update we were expecting did not
happen we thought a blossom tree would
sprout in misty meadow but no
that storyline of the fox clan is being
held off for another update
instead we are going back to the
original hunter mando
and his new game mode mando's bounty and
that comes with this great new poi
kits cantina before we look in detail
here we now know why mando has been
patrolling the desert aimlessly
for 10 weeks now each update he would
change his location which was depicted
by these campsites
and the last update he set up home at
the highest point in the desert biome
overlooking the zero point and now that
spot has become a star wars cantina
with lots of secrets inside first if you
make your way into the back room it's
possible to find this flute saxophone
space thingy which will let you change
the music inside the cantina
it's possible to change the tunes to the
original cantina theme
in the movies this is a copy written
piece of sound so i'm not going to dwell
here but you should totally come back
and rock out
inside this venue all the items in decor
match the tv shows and movies expertly
including more storm trooper helms than
you can imagine they're either buried in
the sand or on pikes to warn off
potential threats
i was going to count them all i can't be
bothered let's just say there's 69 of
them
inside we have a nod to the projections
used in star wars
where the band would usually be playing
but guess who it is
instead do you recognize this guy think
back to december 2019
this is the skin given to jeff keely who
presented the star wars event
back at risky reels all those months ago
do you remember that
by the way that event in 2019 is
actually canon to the star wars timeline
which is the strangest thing to fathom
right now
so have you tried the new mando mode the
lobbies are actually smaller as we use
pucks to track down targets and by
reducing the player count you'll find
more ai controlled enemies here who will
drop
all kinds of loot including all the
exotic weapons
the problem i find playing this mode is
that mando wrecks me
in an instant every time happy days this
update saw a removal of a minor poi
the ghost shadow building next to
mando's new poi
this spot was integral to the story it
was where we found the gnominator too
back in the day remember that and now
it's gone
how many ghosts and shadow locations
still exist on the map these days
has that storyline been forgotten
forever if so
rest in peace midas
here's a very peculiar update which is
not in the game yet
except for on the map look at it look
closely enough and you'll notice that
the map has changed colour and detail
only minor but look at the lake area
near the docks
on the new image this area is now
emptying
the water is becoming a mud but when you
visit their in-game it's just the same
as it's always been
is this foreshadowing of what will
happen next or is this just an update to
the map
well later this week a new rift will
appear here
just by this lake which got me thinking
which hunter will be coming next is it
time to start speculating
my discord has been wondering if this
will be the start of a five nights at
freddy's crossover
as the pond area looks similar to that
one in the game
that would also tie into the clues
johnsy left and maybe those coins
who is your guest for the next hunter to
be added to fortnite
let's have a quick look through the
clues we have the sunglasses which we
all believe now was the terminator that
lines up well
we have hand wraps that could be kratos
we have a necklace a back scratcher
which many of us think this will be the
female variant of midas
we have space bananas i first thought
this would be a
nod to winston from overwatch but now
i'm thinking maybe this is samus
from metroid we have an ant farm i have
no idea what that could link to
i keep going back to kevin bacon you
know from the movie tremors
maybe not we have red and blue sweet
which many of us think was master chief
because of red versus blue
but i'm still thinking this is a matrix
crossover and we're missing something
here
we have face paint that could be kratos
again or maybe rambo
we have rations that could easily be the
walking dead or maybe the gi joe
crossover
we have a mud mask which we all think is
the predator
right and we have a baseball bat i
cannot link to anyone at all and finally
we have
tokens i was thinking this was for
geralt from the witcher who is literally
a hunter but we shall wait and see
okay i've done it again i apologize i
got sidetracked but please help me
complete this list i'll put it in the
comments below
can you name the incoming hunters
so let's talk about the fish in a bowl
if you jump into fortnite right now and
go into your replay files you'll spot
these dining tables around the island i
found three so far one at the der burger
one at the pizza place and one
up at the fish restaurant at each of
these venues you can find leviathan
without his body waiting for his date to
show up for a meal
this is likely for a valentine's day
update in the next week or two
and will have us visiting these spots
for a challenge in terms of detail
you've got to love that the fish is
propped up on a box and a cushion
just to see over the table
short people lives matter let's grab
that i don't want to get cancelled
so that's the update in terms of new map
changes
very soon two new npcs will be coming to
the island
but right now they haven't been
confirmed so i'll wait to talk about
them
on screen now is a list of legends who
kindly use my code in the store
i really appreciate you thank you very
much i'm adam from playstation grenade
it's been a pleasure see you next time
[Applause]
[Music]
you